I have used frankincense in the past seven years ago for a year with no problem, but now when I use it on my breast, my breast starts to feel strange sensations and feels like it's going to leak.
I am using your living bread and my reacting in a negative or positive way.
That's a good question.
So when you have a symptom, you always want to ask, is this a good symptom?
It actually helps you to kill cancer cells and, you know, it's a symptom that is not pleasant, but if it's, if it's helping, the overall outcome, then you could say it's a good symptom or it's a bad symptom.
Well, there's no way that I could know that it's very difficult for you to know that. So one of the things that you can, well, I will say that frankincense can be a hot oil and frankincense kid, you could easily have not an allergic reaction to it, but a sensitivity to it where you could have a sense of hypers.
So it's very possible that that's what is taking place and your body can change even though you might have put it on directly without a carrier oil, the past, you didn't have any issues.
Well, now if it's over your breast tumor where you have a greater amount of inflammation, you're basically, you raise the threshold of inflammation and now you're causing it's tipping over and you're getting skin reactions.
I would think that that's quite possibly what's going on and what you'd want to do to prevent that is to use a carrier oil.
Even if it's a good reaction, you don't necessarily want a wound to open up and your breast to start leaking things like that either. So you don't have to be careful of that.
So I would, I would basically quote unquote water it down using a carrier oil if you want to continue to use it.